in the last video we were able to map
and model the average high temperature
in Santiago Chile is a function of days
as we go through the year where the days
were the days after January 7 so this
right over here de 0 is actually January
7th but we weren't done they want us to
figure out how many days after January
7th is the first spring day when the
temperature reaches 20 degrees Celsius I
had to be careful pay attention to this
whole notion of the first spring day and
the reason is because there's actually
two days where the temperature reaches
20 degrees Celsius so let's say that
this is 20 degrees Celsius right over
here notice you have this day right over
here and then you have this day right
over there and which one is in the
spring or the first spring day well if
this is that we're in summer right over
here we're in summer right over here
when the we're in the southern
hemisphere so our summer is going to be
when it's the winter in the northern
hemisphere is sommore what season comes
after summer well this is going to be
the fall this is going to be the winter
now this is going to be the spring and
then of course you go back to the summer
so we want this value not this value
this one will be the day and fall when
the average high temperatures 20 degrees
Celsius this is the first day of spring
where the average high temperature is 20
degrees Celsius the first spring day oh
I guess it's not necessarily the first
day of spring it's the first spring day
when the temperature reaches 20 degrees
Celsius so this is happening this is
happening in the spring right earlier so
this is the value that we want so let's
just think about that as we try to
manipulate this a little bit so we want
to get to 20 degrees 20 degrees Celsius
so we could write 20 is equal to is
equal to 7.5 times cosine cosine of 2 pi
over 365 times the days times the days
plus 20 1.5 plus twenty 1.5 now we could
subtract 21.5 from both sides and we get
negative 1.5 is equal to and I'll just
copy and paste all of this it's going to
be equal to that
so copy and paste it's going to be equal
to that right over there now I could
divide both sides by 7.5 notice I'm
trying to solve for cosine and
eventually solve for D but we're going
to take a little pause once we have this
in terms of cosine it would be careful
here so we're going to divide both sides
by 7.5 and we're going to get let's see
actually I don't even need a calculator
for this 1.5 divided by 7 point 5 this
is 1/5 5 times 15 is or 5 times 1.5 is
7.5 so this is negative 1/5 or I could
write it as negative 1/5 or I could
write it as negative zero point 2 is
equal to is equal to cosine of 2 pi over
three hundred and sixty five times days
after January 7th times days after
January seventh now this is where we
have to be very very careful instead of
just blindly applying the inverse cosine
function have to make sure which which
angle we are actually getting that we're
getting the right angle right over here
to remember we want the argument to the
cosine that doesn't give us this point
that gives us this point right here or
that corresponds to this point right
over there
so let's let's draw a unit circle just
to just to make sure we know what's
going on I actually do this all the time
especially if I'm trying to apply the
inverse inverse trigonometric functions
in kind of a applied context where I
just can't blindly blindly plug it in
into my calculator so let me draw a unit
circle right over here x-axis y-axis so
circle of radius 1 centered at the
origin so that looks looks well you get
the picture we've done this many times
before and January seventh that
corresponds to this point right over
here that's that point right over here
that we are in the summer we are in the
summer then as the days go by our
argument to the cosine increases the
angle increases and this right over here
will be the fall so this point right
over here so we're at the fall
right over here and then we move on to
the winter the winter right over there
and then finally finally we go to the
spring this is the spring right over
there and we want the angle that gets us
negative 0.2 so this is negative 1
negative 1 negative 0.2 fifth of the way
so it's negative zero point two and
notice there's two angles that get us
there there's this angle and there's
that angle right over there and then
there's also there's also let me draw a
little dotted line here there's that
angle but then there's also this angle
there's also this angle which is going
even even further or another way you
could think about it you could go
backwards to get to that angle and then
if you wanted to go all the way around
to the next spring you could add 2 pi to
it so which one do we want well of
course we want the one in the spring but
if we just blindly apply the inverse
cosine of negative zero point two that's
going to give us this one that's going
to give us this one right over here we
can verify that so let's see inverse
cosine of negative zero point two is one
point seven seven remember this is zero
this is PI right over here so this is
3.14159 and this is one point seven
seven so notice it's a little bit more
than half of Pi which is exactly what it
gave it gave this angle right over here
so this is approximately one point seven
seven radians is this angle is that
angle right over there but we don't want
that one we want this one so how do we
figure that out well we could view it as
we could go all the way around to two pi
and then subtract subtract one point
seven seven so we could say two pi minus
one point seven seven roughly to get
this angle so let's do that so let's
take let's take two two times pi and
then subtract this number and I'm going
to do
second answer so answer is just the
previous answer that I got so that way I
have good precision here so I get four
point five one one and we can we can
kind of make sure that that's the right
thing because that's going to be between
PI and two pi two pi is 2 times 3.14159
so it's going to be six point two eight
something this is 3.14159 this is the
right angle now we're not done yet
that's just the angle that's the
argument that we need to give in here to
get to that point but what's the day's
going to be well 2 PI over 365 days is
going to be equal to this number four
point five one one so let me write that
down so this right over here is going to
be approximately equal to four point
five one one so we scroll down a little
bit we can say 2 PI over 365 times the
days after January seventh is
approximately going to be equal to four
point four point five one one to solve
for days we can just multiply both sides
times the reciprocal of the coefficient
so we're going to multiply both sides
times 365 over two pi that's going to
cancel that's going to cancel and now we
can use our calculator for this so
that's four point that's actually we got
much better precision there so let's
take our previous answer times 365 we
deserve a drum roll here divided by two
divided by two pi and we get 200 and if
we round to the nearest day 262 days
after January 7th
so 262 days and we are done